merci d'être avec nous Dominique Estrosi
ça sonne et nous accompagnons pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes
sénatrice les républicains des
Alpes-Maritimes vice-président de la
commission des affaires économiques et
vous être apporteur de la proposition de
loi anti-squate qui sera examiné cet
après-midi dans l'émission On va
longuement parler dans quelques instants
mais d'abord évidemment l'actualité
c'est cette réforme des retraites
journée de mobilisation aujourd'hui qui
s'annonce suivi est-ce que vous pensez
que le gouvernement peut reculer face à
la rue non je pense que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui est bien évidemment au mur
et qu'il doit aller jusqu'au bout parce
que il en va de du quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron alors on va voir ce
que va donner aujourd'hui ce mardi noir
qui est annoncé effectivement je pense
qu'il va y avoir une très forte
mobilisation mais je dirais qu'après la
réponse elle continue d'appartenir aussi
au syndicat que vont-ils faire est-ce
que le front syndical va être solide
est-ce qu'il va tenir parce qu'on voit
aussi qu'il y a des syndicats qui sont
plus modérés aujourd'hui et qui n'ont
pas envie d'une radicalisation du
mouvement et puis il des syndicats
extrémistes avec une base qui les
aiguillonne et qui tenterait plutôt à
mettre de l'huile sur le feu moi
j'appelle simplement à dire que
l'opinion aujourd'hui elle est
globalement favorable à l'opposition de
la réforme une position à la réforme et
donc au soutien à la mobilisation dans
la rue mais quand sera-t-il s'il y a de
plus en plus de désagréments on va avoir
une première zone de départ en vacances
à la fin de la semaine il y a eu des
annonces qui ont été faites est-ce que
les Français ne vont pas se
désolidariser du soutien à cette
mobilisation dans la rue vous pensez que
c'est avoir un retournement de l'opinion
si les Français sont gênés par
une radicalisation du mouvement s'il y a
des grèves pendant les vacances
scolaires enfin etc je pense que
nonobstant le fait qu'il soit
globalement opposé à la réforme il
pourrait se désolidariser du de la
mobilisation face à la rue et donc
forcément de se dire de toute façon à un
moment donné cette réforme des retraites
elle sera votée vous la soutiendrez
jusqu'au bout vous cette réforme des
retraites qu'est-ce que quel que soit ce
qui se passe dans la rue quel que soit
le nombre de personnes qui iront
manifestées demain et peut-être lors
d'une autre journée alors aujourd'hui
nous on est clair en tout cas le groupe
LR mais la majorité sénatoriale au Sénat
est clair on soutient cette réforme
parce que on l'a voté depuis 2018 via un
amendement où on a la foi toujours
demandé le report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite mais également
qu'il y ait des durées de cotisations
qui soient plus longues 43 à 44 années
donc on peut pas se relier ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui c'est que finalement c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui vient sur notre
réforme qui se saisit de notre réforme
pour la présenter au Parlement parce que
moi je dirais que Emmanuel Macron a fait
souvent des volts face je me souviens
que pendant le précédent mandrin
Emmanuel Macron disait on ne touchera
pas au report de l'âge légal du départ à
la retraite on restera sur 62 ans donc
c'est plutôt lui qui doit expliquer ok
pourquoi il y a ce revirement que nous
qui avons toujours prôné la droite
républicaine qu'il fallait une réforme
des retraites depuis Jacques Chirac
jusqu'à Nicolas Sarkozy parce que nous
voulons sauver notre système par
répartition et qu'aujourd'hui le système
de retraite est structurellement
déficitaire alors on entend dire par le
corps ou par les opposants à la réforme
qu'il y aurait eu un excédent oui il y a
eu un excédent en 2021 de 900 millions
d'euros sauf quand on sait très bien que
dans les 5 années à venir il y aura 15
milliards d'euros de déficit on va
reparler du fond de la réforme avec
Denis carreau dans quelques secondes
mais un dernier mot sur ces
mobilisations est-ce que on l'a vu lors
de la précédente journée il y a eu des
mobilisations pas seulement dans les
grandes villes comme c'est la tradition
mais aussi dans des villes moyennes voir
dans des petites villes est-ce que vous
craignez ce que peut devenir cette
mobilisation est-ce que vous craignez un
effet boule de neige avec des Français
qui sont en colère sur beaucoup de
sujets et qui pourraient venir
manifester pas seulement contre la
réforme des retraites oui bien sûr c'est
une réalité aujourd'hui on voit bien que
à partir de la réforme des retraites la
colère des Français ne cesse de monter
ne cesse de gronder et que on accumule
autour un certain nombre de difficultés
que rencontre les Français il y a une
crise sociale dans notre pays à une
véritable fracture territoriale il y a
des problèmes au niveau de l'énergie et
donc tout cela peut
s'aggloutiner pour montrer que la
réforme des retraites va servir de
catalyseur à une colère qui sera
beaucoup plus froide et beaucoup plus
importante c'est un risque et c'est un
risque à travers toute la France
puisqu'on a vu effectivement que tous
les territoires des plus petits ou des
plus reculés jusqu'au plus importants
ont été touchés par cette mobilisation
massive on va parler du fond du texte on
va chez vous à Nice on nous attend de
nicaro bonjour Dany merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous directeur des
rédactions de Nice-Matin et Denis je le
disais on parle du fond du texte puisque
à la Une de Nice-Matin et évidemment
dans vos pages se pose la question de
l'emploi des seniors
oui Oriane effectivement on le voit bien
l'emploi des seniors est au cœur du
débat sur la réforme des retraites il
faudra travailler plus longtemps plus
vieux encore faut-il conserver son
travail et si ce n'est pas le cas
pouvoir en retrouver un dans les
Alpes-Maritimes et dans le Var
aujourd'hui un tiers des demandeurs
d'emploi ont plus de 50 ans alors anis
ce matin on a voulu s'intéresser aux
entreprises qui clairement misent sur
les seniors on en a rencontré deux c'est
le cas notamment d'une entreprise
niçoise elle s'appelle Converse
télémarketing et elle emploie plus d'un
tiers de seniors parmi ces 180 salariés
et tous les jours les dirigeants de
cette entreprise se félicitent de ce
choix il nous explique que les salariés
de plus de 50 ans sont à la fois plus
assidus plus investi et peut-être même
plus en phase avec les valeurs de de
l'entreprise et Converse les marketing
vient même de recruter un nouvel il a 70
ans et il est employé à temps partiel
alors évidemment ces entreprises qui
font la part belle au seniors font
aujourd'hui figures d'exception mais
c'est un message intéressant qui est
envoyé au moment où on explique aux
Français qu'ils vont devoir travailler
plus longtemps alors j'en viens à ma
question Dominique Estrosi saunson le
gouvernement a prévu dans le projet de
loi de mettre en place un index senior
qui devrait être rendu public sous peine
de sanctions est-ce que ce dispositif
vous paraît être suffisant pour inciter
vraiment les entreprises à employer des
seniors
alors non je pense que il s'agit plus
d'un gadget cette index des seniors
parce qu'on voit bien d'abord qu'il
n'est pas coercitif ce n'est que
déclaratif on ne sera accentionné que si
on n'apporte pas les renseignements dans
l'index des seniors mais si le taux
d'emploi des seniors n'augmente pas et
bien l'entreprise devra simplement
ouvrir une négociation salariale
beaucoup plus renforcée donc je pense
que ce n'est pas la solution c'est une
chose qui permet effectivement de
mesurer le taux d'emploi des seniors
mais vous l'exprimiez très bien de
nicaro il faut changer le regard sur
l'âge il faut véritablement que non
seulement les employeurs et vous avez
cité des entreprises qui ont bien
compris mais aussi que le gouvernement
considère qu'il faut faire plus de place
aux personnes qui sont proches de la
retraite qu'il faut voir aussi que nous
sommes le pays dans lequel les personnes
entre 60 et 64 ans travaillent le moins
dans les entreprises et en contrepartie
on a un taux de chômage des seniors qui
est plus important que la moyenne donc
je pense que véritablement il faut que
tout le monde se saisisse de ce sujet
bien sûr le gouvernement à travers ce
texte de loi mais aussi des entreprises
et pour cela je pense que la première
des choses c'est de changer le regard
sur l'âge aujourd'hui on considère dans
les entreprises souvent que finalement
les seniors c'est une charge économique
que ça peut être un risque pour la
productivité or au contraire on voit
qu'il faut encourager la transmission la
transmission des savoir-faire la
transmission du savoir à être comment
dire que un salarié senior peut
transmettre à un jeune qui débute qui
apprend le métier il faut valoriser
l'expérience il faut valoriser aussi le
mécénat de compétences et c'est comme sa
véritablement qu'on arrivera à faire en
sorte que l'emploi des seniors se
développe dans les entreprises dans
notre pays
Denis vous avez votre réponse que vous
avez une autre question
non j'ai ma réponse et dans les
dispositifs Dominique Estrosi Sassone
qu'on pourrait qu'on pourrait imaginer
plus précisément pour favoriser l'emploi
des seniors je pense qu'il faut regarder
du côté du dispositif de la retraite
progressive là il y a des marges de
manœuvre à améliorer il faut aussi
assouplir je le disais à transmission et
la transition entre l'emploi et la
retraite permettent de toucher une
partie de sa retraite tout en occupant
un emploi à temps partiel et puis enfin
il faut aussi continuer à accompagner le
dispositif du cumul emploi retraite je
pense que ça passe aussi par là pour
qu'on arrive à avoir un meilleur taux
d'emploi des seniors merci beaucoup
Denis d'avoir été avec nous regarde la
Une de Nice-Matin aujourd'hui le
casse-tête des seniors c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup Denis
carreau d'avoir été avec nous depuis
Nice est-ce qu'il y a d'autres points
d'amélioration à apporter sur ce texte
pour vous Dominique espositation on a
notamment entendu suite aux propos de
Franck Riester la question des femmes
les inquiétudes sur la question des
femmes qui seraient un peu pénalisé
c'est ce qu'a dit le ministre est-ce que
là aussi il faut travailler à des points
d'amélioration sur ce texte oui nous
l'avons dit et nous le ferons nous y
veillerons nous serons exigeants c'est
le dispositif de minimum de pension mais
c'est aussi effectivement la
problématique des carrières hachées des
femmes elles ne sont pas un peu
pénalisées elles sont beaucoup
pénalisées par rapport aux hommes et il
faut aller plus loin en matière aussi de
droit familiaux et donc c'est un des
points sur lesquels nous serons
extrêmement exigeants pour que nous
puissions faire en sorte de faire que
ces femmes qui ne soient pas trop
pénalisés par cette réforme des
retraites alors qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement elles le sont et elles
risquent de continuer à l'être un
dernier mot puisque les députés les
républicains ont déposé un amendement
pour que tous ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 21 ans se voient
appliquer le critère des annuités donc
des 43 unités et pas celui de l'âge ils
ne seront pas obligés d'aller jusqu'à on
vous êtes d'accord avec ça oui j'y suis
favorable je pense que sur les carrières
longues le gouvernement a déjà annoncé
un certain nombre de choses mais pour
les personnes qui ont travaillé entre 16
ans et 20 ans je crois qu'effectivement
ils ne peuvent il ne faut pas prendre
encore le critère de l'âge mais celui
des cotisations et leur permettre de
partir lorsqu'ils auront les 43 années
de cotisations vous pensez que les
républicains voteront ce texte à
l'Assemblée nationale écoutez je n'en
sais rien je vois aujourd'hui qu'il y a
des voies discordantes dans le groupe
les républicains à l'Assemblée nationale
j'ose espérer que la discussion
parlementaire amènera à ce qu'il y ait
une cohérence au sein de leur groupe
comme nous pouvons l'avoir et comme nous
l'aurons nous au sein du groupe LR au
Sénat vous dites que vous électeurs ne
comprendrez pas que les républicains les
parlementaires des républicains ne
votent pas cette réforme bien on le voit
les électeurs DLR montrent aujourd'hui
qu'ils veulent cette réforme parce que
on l'a toujours prôné parce qu'on a
toujours dit qu'on la ferait on l'a fait
par le passé il faut continuer
aujourd'hui à la faire parce que bien
évidemment il faut revenir au regard du
déficit qui s'est accru et donc
effectivement il faudra bien l'expliquer
il faudra aussi montrer les gains que
nous pourrions obtenir à travers la
discussion parlementaire mais au bout du
compte il faudra la voter on va passer à
l'actualité du Sénat et elle vous
concerne évidemment Dominique est choisi
ça sonne puisque le Sénat examinent
aujourd'hui un texte pour lutter contre
les occupations illicites de logement
vous en êtes à apporter on va voir ce
que contient ce texte avec Alex tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Ariane bonjour Dominique ça
sonne
alors à cette proposition
alors c'est un texte qui est à
l'initiative de député de la majorité
présidentielle mais qui s'inspire de ce
que vote la majorité de droite du Sénat
depuis des années pour réprimer le squat
de certains logements ce texte il durcit
la peine encourue en cas de violation de
domicile pour atteindre et bien trois
ans de prison et 45000 euros d'amende il
crée aussi un nouveau délit d'occupation
illicite d'un local à usage d'habitation
comme une résidence secondaire ou à
usage économique et puis ce texte il
renforce également les peines pour les
autres délits qui sont liés au squat
notamment pour les marchands de sommeil
qui organisent ces occupations et les
sites de logement ils encourent la même
peine trois ans de prison 45000 euros
d'amende comme les squatteurs et puis
pour ceux qui en font la promotion sur
les réseaux sociaux et bien ces
personnes risquent une amende de
3750 euros on va écouter le député
Renaissance et auteur de ce texte à
Guillaume gaspareillan député
d'Eure-et-Loir celles et ceux d'entre
vous qui ont reçu un jour dans la
permanence un citoyen dans le domicile
esquatté ou un propriétaire dont est
occupé par un locataire qui ne paye plus
depuis des années savent que la
situation actuelle ne peut plus durer
nous avons le devoir d'agir c'est ce
qu'attendent les victimes et avec cette
proposition de loi s'intéresse aussi aux
impayés de loyer ah oui effectivement ce
texte va accélérer le la procédure de
contentieux locatif qui peut parfois
prendre du temps et durée plus de deux
ans là ça ira quelques mois plus vite et
puis le contrat de location sera
également automatiquement résilié en cas
d'impayé de loyer c'est une clause qui
existe souvent dans les dans les bails
mais là elle sera imposée de manière
obligatoire dans le contrat de location
alors politiquement la majorité de
droite du Sénat devrait adopter ce texte
mais en le modifiant quand même pour
éviter les amalgames entre les
squatteurs et les locataires qui sont en
situation d'un pays loyer qui ont
parfois des difficultés financières et
c'est amalgame que les députés de gauche
ont pointé du doigt lors du débat à
l'Assemblée nationale sur cette
proposition de loi un débat qui était
très tendu
on essaie de médiatiser des situations
qui sont gravissimes scandaleuses mais
exceptionnelle qui est celui de la
violation de domicile pour lequel tout
l’argental juridique existe pour
finalement durcir la législation pour
accélérer les expulsions locatives des
gens qui sont difficultés de paiement
c'est ça la réalité de cette loi c'est
pas la lutte contre les squats Dominique
esprit ça sonne qu'est-ce que vous allez
répondre aux arguments de gauche dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat la gauche qui est
contre cette proposition de loi et qui
estime que ce texte il pénalise la
précarité écoutez je pense que dans le
texte qui est sorti de la commission
nous avons essayé justement de prendre
en compte cet équilibre qui est
nécessaire et surtout vous l'avez
signalé de distinguer la situation du
squatteur de la situation du locataire
qui se trouve en difficulté elles ne
sont pas comparables elles ne sont pas
semblables donc c'est une première des
choses nous regrettons simplement parce
que j'avais moi-même déposé une
proposition de loi en janvier 2021 pour
garantir la propriété immobilière contre
le squat cette proposition de loi elle a
été votée au Sénat il y a deux ans et
nous avons regretté que la majorité
présidentielle n'est pas inscrit plutôt
notre proposition de loi aujourd'hui
elle serait votée et elle pourrait être
mise en application donc que de temps
perdu comment pour autant pourquoi la
majorité présidentielle a deux ans de
retard du coup par rapport à votre
demande pour finalement présenter un
texte qui sur certains points reprend
l'intégralité des mesures qui étaient
contenues dans ma proposition de loi
tout simplement je pense que il n'avait
pas conscience de la situation et
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont voulu quelque
part montrer que c'était eux qui étaient
à la manœuvre ces regrettable sont ces
politiques il voulait pas voter un texte
de la droite il y avait forcément les
deux mais ce que je regrette si je
partage l'esprit et l'objectif général
de cette proposition de loi je regrette
quand même que effectivement cette
proposition de loi stigmatise les
locataires qui sont en difficulté c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
amender le texte parce que il faut bien
prendre en considération que les squats
sont certes une violation terrible de
l'intimité et ils doivent être réprimés
sans faiblesse sauf que les squats sont
finalement peu nombreux dans notre pays
ils occupent l'actualité médiatique mais
on voit qu'en 2021 il y a eu par exemple
160 saisines de juges par rapport à des
squats et qui donc sont terminés pour
70% uniquement par l'occupant qui est
parti volontairement et le reste
effectivement par un concours de la
force publique après il y a un phénomène
de masse qui est le phénomène des
impayés de loyer grosso modo 500 000
impayés de loyer au moment du
commandement de payer mais là aussi ça
se divise par 3 puisqu'il n'y a plus
trois ans après que 120000 assignations
devant le juge qui se traduisent aussi
soit par des expulsions soit par des
expulsions conditionnelles qui sont donc
limitées de la dette donc on voit aussi
que ce qui est important c'est d'agir
très en amont par rapport à la
prévention des impayés et des expulsions
et cette partie là elle était
complètement absente du texte de
l'Assemblée nationale donc d'où on a
rien introduit ces mesures pour donner
plus de moyens d'agir au commissions de
coordination de prévention des actions
d'expulsion locative pour qu'elle puisse
elle-même juger pour qu'elle puisse
maintenir ou suspendre les allocations
logement par exemple pour qu'elle puisse
aussi demander par exemple un juge de
consigner directement les prestations
sociales du locataire qui est défaillant
sur le compte du bailleur donc
finalement on est plus sévère plus
stricte contre les squatteurs contre les
locataires de mauvaise foi qui
délibérément décide de ne pas payer leur
loyer et de ne pas respecter un plan
d'apurement de la dette locative mais on
veut agir plus en amont de façon plus
précoce pour faire en sorte que on
puisse aussi mieux accompagner
socialement des locataires qui
rencontrent un accident de la vie sans
que pour autant ça ne porte bien sûr sur
des propriétaires est-ce qu'il fallait
un nouveau texte répressif contre le
squat car vous le dites il y a peu de
squats chaque année en France et il
existe déjà un arsenal législatif pour
le réprimer il y avait une peine d'un an
de prison qu'est-ce que c'est nécessaire
d'aller encore plus loin oui parce que
il y avait encore quelques trous dans la
raquette si vous me le permettez c'est
vrai que on ne visait que les locaux à
usage d'habitation là sont visés aussi
les locaux à usage professionnel c'est
important c'est important pourquoi parce
qu'on nous dit mais regardez ces locaux
sont vacants les associations qui
luttent contre le mal logement et bien
pourquoi ne pas les
occuper sauf que les occupés c'est les
occupés de façon illégale alors
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un dispositif que
nous encourageons dans le texte de loi
qui est le dispositif du logement
intérimaire qui permet justement à des
sociétés privées qui sont agréés par
l'État à des associations de pouvoir
louer locaux vacants à des personnes de
façon temporaire qui peuvent être aussi
bien des personnes en difficulté mais
aussi par exemple des salariés en
mobilité géographique ou en mobilité
professionnelle le temps du changement
d'usage des locaux qui sont vacants le
temps des travaux qu'il puisse être
entrepris et au bout de l'occupation
temporaire et bien les locaux doivent
redevenir vides et nous avons même voulu
éviter la requalification de ces locaux
en bail classique justement pour
permettre donc à partir du moment où il
y a un dispositif qui est là qui est
gagnant gagnant pour tout le monde et
bien il y a pas de raison de ne pas
interdire l'occupation illégale de
locaux à usage professionnel il y a
aussi ce qui n'avait pas été prévu c'est
quand une personne se diffussement
propriétaire d'un bien qu'elle fait
rentrer dans ce bien un locataire qui se
retrouve involontairement en situation
de squat parce qu'il a fait confiance à
la personne qui se disait propriétaire
du bien donc là il faut véritablement
sanctionner il faut continuer à
sanctionner les marchands de sommeil et
puis il y a aussi quelque chose
d'intéressant qui est le principe
d'exonération de la responsabilité du
propriétaire lorsque il peut y avoir un
défaut d'entretien sur le bien qui lui
appartient mais comme il ne peut pas
rentrer dans le bien parce qu'il est
occupé de façon illicite il ne doit pas
être responsable d'un défaut d'entretien
qui pourrait causer un dommage à autrui
donc ne serait-ce que pour tous ces
cas-là il fallait effectivement
continuer à renforcer la loi contre le
squat vous avez apporté beaucoup de
modifications à cette rue est-ce que du
coup vous êtes optimiste sur son vote
final je pense que la proposition de loi
sera votée par la majorité sénatoriale
mais après sera pas voté par
l'opposition au Sénat même si mes
collègues lorsqu'on a présenté le
rapport en commission considère qu'on a
rééquilibré le texte et sont
effectivement favorables à toutes les
mesures d'accompagnement soci normal qui
vise à prévoir une accompagnement
renforcée et agir en amont sur la
prévention des impayés et des expulsions
mais il considéreront toujours qu’on en
fait jamais assez mais moi ce que je
veux dire c'est que un texte aussi qui
est à destination des propriétaires nous
nous y tenons parce que les
propriétaires il faut arrêter de penser
qu'ils sont nés que ce sont tous des
riches propriétaires on voit bien que
deux tiers des propriétaires n'ont qu'un
seul bien en location qui leur permet un
complément de retraite ce qui est
important aussi de signaler c'est que
bien sûr il faut protéger les
propriétaires contre les squats mais il
y a aussi des accidents à la propriété
qui n'étaient pas prises en compte il y
a aussi les personnes qui sont
attributaires dans le logement social et
qui ne peuvent pas rentrer dans le
logement tout simplement parce qu'elles
y trouvent un squatteur alors qu'elle
continue en supporter la charge et bien
ces cas-là n'étaient pas prévu dans la
loi aujourd'hui si la proposition de loi
est votée et bien ils le seront et donc
ça permet là aussi de continuer à
accompagner à protéger les propriétaires
parce qu'au bout du compte qu'est-ce
qu'il va se passer sinon qu'est-ce qu'il
se passe déjà et bien les propriétaires
vont ne plus investir les propriétaires
vont ne plus louer leur bien en longue
durée il préféreront faire du Airbnb et
cela accroîtra la crise du logement avec
vous avez une dernière question oui au
fond ça pose la question du mal logement
est-ce que la politique du gouvernement
ces dernières années sur ce sujet est
assez efficace selon non non la
politique du logement est défaillante en
la matière s'il y a pas assez de
construction de logements s'il n'y a pas
assez d'attribution de logements et plus
particulièrement de logements sociaux ce
n'est pas de la faute des propriétaires
c'est bien de la faute du gouvernement
et les propriétaires n'ont pas à
supporter la charge du mal logement je
serai demain à la Fondation Abbé Pierre
puisque j'interviens sur une table ronde
bien évidemment qu'on doit continuer à
éradiquer ce mal logement mais la cause
première c'est une politique défaillante
du gouvernement en matière de logement
on n'a jamais connu des chiffres de la
construction de logements aussi bas et
pourquoi ce serait les propriétaires qui
en seraient rendus responsables alors
que le gouvernement lui doit continuer à
faire des efforts et avoir une politique
volontariste en la matière merci Alex à
tout à l'heure on parlera de lopinion
face à la réforme des retraites
pour Public Sénat la presse régionale
merci beaucoup Alexandre dernier mot sur
un autre texte qui va arriver au Sénat
ce sera en mars c'est le projet de loi
immigration il va être présenté demain
en Conseil des ministres le Sénat qui va
l'examiner en premier alors c'est un
texte qui allie fermeté et humanité
c'est ce que dit le gouvernement c'est
ce que dit Gérald Darmanin il y a à la
fois des mesures qui durcissent les
arrivées et la politique migratoire et
puis il y a cette fameuse mesure qui
donne des titres de séjour aux
travailleurs étrangers dans les métiers
en tension travailleur en situation
irrégulière est-ce que c'est un texte
qui selon le débat parlementaire
pourrait avoir votre vote non en l'état
il n'aura pas notre bien évidemment
parce que nous sommes opposés à la
régularisation des étrangers sur le
terme de métiers en tension parce
qu'aujourd'hui tous les métiers sont en
tension donc c'est ouvrir les vannes de
l'immigration nous nous voulons que
soient mis en place le principe de la
régularisation 0 c'est-à-dire toute
clandestin illégale doit savoir qu'il ne
pourra jamais être régularisé et nous
voulons rétablir le séjour illégal qui
avait été supprimé par François Hollande
mais pour autant ce texte et bien comme
nous le faisons à chaque fois au Sénat
nous ne réécrirons à partir d'un certain
nombre de mesures qui ont été proposées
en particulier par le président de la
commission des lois François Noel buffet
mais nous ne voulons absolument pas
aller dans le sens du gouvernement parce
qu'on le voit bien aujourd'hui la
politique migratoire du gouvernement est
une Bérézina et elle annonce un
véritable défectif le gouvernement il
dit mais nous on va dans le sens de
François Noel buffet ce texte il
s'inspire beaucoup du rapport sénatorial
c'est pour vous c'est non non il
s'inspire pas profond de certains nombre
de mesures que je vous ai rappelés et
auxquelles nous sommes particulièrement
attachés merci à l'examen de ce texte ce
sera au mois de mars au Sénat merci
beaucoup
et on rappelle que la proposition de loi
pour lutter contre le patient illicite
des logements est examiné aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle on suivra tout ça merci
d'avoir été avec nous pour nous en
parler dans 20 minutes dans le club des
territoires on repart évidemment réforme
des retraites journée de mobilisation
aujourd'hui on sera à
Montpellier et
à performance se prépare la mobilisation
dans nos régions et puis vous
découvrirez ce sondage exclusif au doxa
pour publique Sénat quelle vision
avez-vous de cette réforme ce sera dans
20 minutes d'abord on accueille notre
prochain invité c'est Fabien Roussel